we're asked which of the following
vectors have the same X component as
vector a and they tell us to select all
that apply so this is vector a right
over here we only have to concern
ourselves with the X component that's
what they're asking us about so let's
think about what its X component is
we're starting at this point right over
here which has an x value of negative 2
and we're going from negative 2 to or
we're going from x equals negative 2 to
X is equal to negative 5 so our change
in X or what another way to think about
our X component we're going from
negative 2 to negative 5 we just our x
value goes down by 3 so we have negative
3 we could say our change in X is equal
to negative 3 or that would also be the
X component of vector a we could say
that vector a is equal to its X
component is negative 3
we're not concerning ourselves with our
Y component but we see that our Y goes
up by 1 so it's negative 3 comma 1 but
we just want to we just care about our X
component so let's think about what
other vectors here have an X component
of negative 3 that if we start at our
initial point and go to the terminal
point our x value has gone down by 3
well we're going to start with vector
with vector B here and let's see if we
start there if we start our x value is 3
and our initial point our starting point
for that vector and then to go to the x
value of the terminal point we once
again we went down by 3 so this has the
same X component vector B vector B is
going to be negative 3 comma something
so I will select that one let's think
about vector C vector C starts here at x
equals negative 4 and then it ends at x
equals negative 1 so it's X component is
going to look one way to think about it
our change in X is going to look like
this and you might be tempted to say
this the same thing it has a length of 3
but notice we're not going 3 to the left
the way that we did in vector a and
vector B we're going 3 to the right so
here our change in X is positive 3
and so vector C vector C is going to be
positive three comma something so it's
not going to be vector C now let's look
at vector D vector D starts over here
that's its x value is negative six and
we're going from x equals negative six
to x equals negative nine so once again
we have gone down our change in X is
negative three so that has the same X
component if I were to say vector D I
would say it's negative three comma
something I haven't figured out what
these are but I don't need to for this
problem so vector D also has the same X
component and X component of negative
three and we're done